all right well one of the ways we're
getting through the wednesday show
opening up the twitter lines for
questions from your crowd with chris
sims unbuttoned my group the pft pm
posse and we'll whip through some of
these first one that we have comes from
at gigi mcdonald if you were joe burrow
chris would you pull an eli or an elway
and refuse to go to the cincinnati
bengals ah no i would not uh you know i
i just first off joe burrow you know
correct me if i'm wrong here i know he
was born in iowa but he played high
school football in ohio right you get a
chance to go back to your home state you
know and honestly
you know sometimes i just look at these
type of situations in cincinnati and
just go there's nowhere to go but up i
understand it hasn't been always pretty
but it's a chance to be reached
legendary status too you know i think
that's what guys like baker mayfield and
kyla murray realized with the cardinals
and the browns they just went well
nobody's ever gone here and really
dominated and i planned to do that and i
think that would be a cool opportunity
for joe burrow and to be the number one
pick and do all that is very special uh
i would not do that if i was joe burrow
yeah i mean it's weird he's from ohio he
was at ohio state he transferred away
from ohio state and it all happened for
him at lsu but you know i
i i like the idea of building something
and going to a team that's never won a
super bowl going to a team where the sky
is the limit where the fan base is
scattering they need a guy like ger boro
to bring everything together uh because
they're just irrelevant right now and
burrow would make them relevant right
out of the gate so i would go ahead and
do it if i were he right maverick 50
what wrinkle would you like to see green
bay's offense add to give them more of a
chance against the san francisco 49ers
defense chris oh that's a that's a real
good question now you know they're good
play actions they're pretty good in the
boot game they run the ball pretty well
you know i always talk about mike that
their drop back pass game is not real
imaginative to me but you're not gonna
change that at this point the one thing
i would say about that that jumps out to
me and we saw this a little early on in
the game last week if you remember mike
they had some of those like you know
shanahan we're gonna toss it to the
right but yet the receiver from the
right came from that way and i tossed it
to him going the other way right number
32 irving i think they gave him a few in
the first half i would like to see more
of those type of runs misdirection they
need to do a little bit more just to
keep people honest off their bread and
butter run place to me and that's where
it makes shanahan so special on the
offensive side of the ball and their run
game is they have yeah we have really
good meat and potatoes run plays but we
got a few other run plays that are like
hey up yours you're not going to stop
this
every game that are game plan creative i
would love to see a little bit of that
take some pressure off the run game make
the defense think slow down a really
fast aggressive front seven of the san
francisco 49ers so i would say some of
those misdirection run plays i guess is
how i'd classify it
you know my thought wouldn't really
constitute a new wrinkle but it's more
of something that we see from time to
time and it's that sandlot element that
aaron rodgers brings to the table i hear
he's got that unspoken communication
with devante adams we argued last week
that the vikings should attack as best
they could the secondary the 49ers and
they just weren't able to i'd like to
see devante adams over on richard
sherman's side of the field and see what
adams and rogers can cook up to get him
wide open and just different things
where
it's just that feel it's that look and
it's that back foot flip right here you
know we we showed yesterday chris your
breakdown of the throw to jimmy graham
the 27 yarder where it drops in over the
top and you said i don't know where his
feet are going here i mean it's amazing
how he can make it happen off of all the
different platforms his body in
different positions and he's got that
arm strength where he can just drop it
in and you throw on top of it that that
improvisation that has come out at times
this year yeah that's what i want to see
more of just a sense that he's got a
he's got a rock and a twig and a bottle
cap and they're just drawing it up on
the fly and it's working i i meg i hear
you there and i don't think that's
necessarily hey protect it up let
devonte adams work one-on-one on the
outside i don't care if it's mosley or
sherman you know adams and and and
rogers combination is special in that
and i i don't think you're wrong there
i'm still waiting to see somebody attack
the 49ers that way i think that's what
needs to be done and yes you're i mean
mike come on mahomes rogers have we ever
seen quarterbacks who can throw the ball
for more awkward weird positions fading
away one leg both legs off the ground
it's unreal what they do and rogers made
some throws in that game the other night
that you know 36 years old the way that
he's still doing it is truly remarkable
i remember when the chiefs and the
packers were getting ready to play on a
sunday night during the season mahomes
was injured and you were very upset yes
because you wanted to see that aaron
rodgers patrick mahomes showdown and we
may be seeing it in two and a half yeah
but i got a roofer kyle shanahan on the
49ers so it's all messed up i mean it's
all messed up i don't know what to do
speaking of kyle shanahan the next
question comes from brian alonzo 89 do
you think shanahan was sending a message
to jimmy g by running the ball after the
interception well i mean to a degree i
mean i don't think he was like i'm gonna
show you and send you a message and run
the ball no matter what i mean i think
you know
it was a message in like hey i'm scared
as hell i don't know what the hell
you're gonna do with the ball you threw
the ball into like a mosh put of players
about three or four different times you
know hey yeah jimmy garoppolo you know
we were there we saw it we saw him throw
a winner one interception what do you
think the vikings did drop two three
other ones right mike so i think that
scared the hell out of shanann and he
finally realized listen my run game is
dominating up front it might not be sexy
and fun but i'm just gonna smash it in
there for five and six yards at a time
because yeah i think he was a little
worried about the way jimmy garoppolo
was seeing the field and playing at that
moment
and it's kind of strange i think about
what happened in the third quarter there
was another near miss on second and five
the opening drive in the third quarter
but on third down he connected with
kendrick bourne for a 20-yard gain and
then that's when they went into run run
the ball run the ball run the ball mode
and look if you can get five or six
yards at a clip and you demoralize the
defense chew up the clock i don't know
that he was sending a message to jimmy
garoppolo i just think he was doing what
he had to do to win the game right and
at that point he knew this is how we win
the game yeah that's that's exactly
right and he just knew if i can win the
game that way and i don't even have to
roll the dice on jimmy making a good
throw or a bad decision or whatever it
may be so be it let's just do it that
way
next question comes from displaced chief
kelsey or kittle i guess all of twitter
wants to know of course travis kelsey
chief tight end george kittle 49ers
tight end which guy do you prefer well
i think
i think i would have preferred george
kittle i would now both of these guys
are awesome we know that kelsey
may be a little more nuanced as a route
runner and things like that than george
kittle i mean kelsey's very special that
way but blocking certainly taking george
kittle that's not even close you know
yards after catch and physicality with
the ball in their hand certainly going
george kittle there
and you know i think george kittle's
faster at this point too you know i
don't know if he's quite as slippery and
as smooth in the pass routes but
everything else i give give george
kittle the advantage there so i'm going
kiddle what about you
well and it's look and i like both guys
a lot and i feel like with kittle
you don't just have a tight end you've
got a warrior you've got a football
player you've got a guy who's going to
get the team fired up you've got a guy
who's presence i mean he had three
catches for 15 yards on saturday against
the vikings and it's not like he was
sulking on the sidelines he was as as
fired up after the game running around
like a crazy man i mean that you just i
think you need that spirit right on an
nfl team it's easy for guys to get jaded
and they're you know they're hurt and
and you know they're they're pros it's
not college it's not high school a
little that rah-rah i think is good and
george kittle brings the full package to
the 49ers he does he does uh kelsey's a
great leader too but you're right george
kittle like personifies i think the kind
of attitude kyle shanahan wants out of
the leaders on his football team and
that's why where he's special
all right at the jay carmichael how did
the chief stop derek henry if chris
jones is a scratch again jones day to
day with a calf injury that kept him
from playing on sunday against the texas
well yeah that would be a huge blow i
mean chris jones you could sit here and
argue he's the second best player on the
kansas city chiefs other than patrick
mahomes i mean that's what was
impressive about last weekend the fact
that their defense played that well
without him
uh now they can stop derek henry you
know the difference between what kansas
city was doing maybe you know week 10
and before and then where they're at now
is they just got a lot of players that
are playing at a higher level i mean one
xavier williams is back healthy they got
kalin sanders number 99 325 pound
defensive tackle who's really come on
the last half of the season terrell
suggs of course him you know
passing young number 92 has played
phenomenal football for them so they've
had a lot derek nandy they've had a lot
of other big guys step up for their
football team and that's really what has
helped them become a lot better on the
defensive side of the ball so i still
think they can be very effective in run
demons the big thing with chris jones
where they miss him more than anything
yeah he's good against the run he's a
superstar against the pass he's other
than aaron donald the best interior
defensive tackle pass rusher in all of
football
and that's where they will miss him a
lot because he can push the pocket and
create havoc that way i think in the run
game though they can be okay without him
mike
yeah and peter king and i were talking
about this yesterday with the titans and
derek henry
it really has become almost like middle
school football where there's the one
big kid
who
no one can stop and they just give him
the ball over and over again and and the
and everybody knows he's getting the
ball but you can't stop him because he
is a freight train with a rocket up his
butt yes
no one can get in his way i mean you
can't simulate it in practice bill
belichick always takes away what the
opposing offense does best couldn't take
away derek henry no matter how hard he
tried and and you know we're going to be
picking games tomorrow and man
i'm very tempted to take the titans
because i don't think the chiefs can
stop the guy we'll see how that all
plays out carrie 078 and this isn't a
question chris as much as it is an
observation congrats on not getting in
the ref's way this time around with the
gray lebrons on
there was no moment on saturday in santa
clara of chris sims oh and there it is
right on control
there's sims and there it is you're just
a little too close to the white line and
there he goes you know what
all the snow we showed yesterday the
time lapse of the removal of the snow at
arrowhead stadium they have a new
procedure this year all that snow was
gone they got it out see that's why you
were to maybe you it was a little tight
change you prompted the procedural
change at arrowhead stadium because you
get too close to the field so they got
to get all that snow out so it's the
chris sims i'm glad i could help i would
i hope they would call it that but what
did i say to you on the first drive of
the game when we were on the sidelines
49ers vikings remember what i said to
you about two plays and i said hey guys
look for refs watch out you know because
i'm i'm like scarred for life by it
between that and being on the sidelines
of notre dame all i did this year was
worrying about dodging ref so i didn't
become a social media idiot once again
we did post a photo over the weekend of
the crew at the game and you had these
big giant lebrons on and somebody wanted
to know what the shoes were and somebody
else chimed in and said they're the ref
tripper three
that is the brand we need to get you a
shoe we need to get nike
under armour reebok
i'm all nike mike i got to go to that
way
uh the ref tripper three coming soon to
a store near you last question very
important and this comes from the
marshawn lynch admonition that was made
earlier this week dave ali
556-89793 have to be complete did you
take care of your chicken chris and by
the way we've come to the conclusion
after careful analysis and study that
when marshawn lynch tells young players
to take care of their chicken he's
talking about their money did you take
care of your chicken uh yup i took care
of my chicken my chicken's real good
yeah i learned some new things this week
taking care of your chicken if you don't
want this the flu to spread you wash
your hands and wash your ass i mean i
got it all taken care of learned a lot
of things this week
the actual quote from davonte adams was
wash your hands wash your butt of course
you're going to skew in the way that's
going to get us in trouble
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports